mon
le
[Musique]
notez d'hellemmes avec stanislas rigaux
le président de la génération z
absolument c'est alex tanis l'os meego
président de génération au sein des
membres de l'organisation de ce meeting
bonjour stanislas bonjour salissage en à
vue de quelques petites échauffourées la
l'instant qu'est ce qui s'est passé à ce
que j'en savais plus si j'ai bien
compris au vu des informations qui m'a
donné aussi l'inde à part des
journalistes et des militants de la
sécurité des journalistes du quotidien
est en train d'interroger quelqu'un ils
ont commencé à être hué le mouvement de
foule entraînant en traînant toujours
des attitudes un peu y réfléchit tout a
commencé lui il ya eu lieu et la
sécurité de soutien comme celle de comme
celle d'eric zemmour a décidé
d'exfiltrer ils ont été mis dans un coin
tranquillement pour tous soit apaisée
ils sont revenus vers leur image
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lanthier